so I saw dr. Holden's video and enjoyed
it the videos I feel like was kind of
framed as a counterpoint almost but
actually watching it I really didn't
disagree with very much of it at all
I think probably the area in which we
diverge is that I think the default
artificial general intelligence if you
were to build one without any particular
concern for safety would be a bad one
would be one that we don't want to build
that would try to do things we don't
want it to do and I talked about this in
the earlier videos when I was talking
about the space of general Minds or the
space of motivations this is the kind of
thing that the stamp collector
machines creator was expecting to happen
human values are complicated right they
are complicated and we don't really know
what they are fully and anything that
has values that aren't very tightly
aligned to ours is not a thing we want
to be building
yeah I talked to to dr. Holm about this
but almost everything in that video I
agree with I agree about the timescales
I agree that we are a long way away from
the kind of thing that I'm talking about
or with that we're probably a long way
away right in the previous video I stand
by the video but I think I came across
as overconfident just because of the way
that it was framed like I didn't choose
the title the deadly truth you call
something the truth capital T you know
it was a thought experiment it was a I
wouldn't I would have called it an
interesting thought experiment about
general artificial intelligence or
something like that there's an argument
in mind I've got quite so many views
yeah I'm not going to try and tell you
how to do your job you know but no the
actual content of the video I stand by
so there was really only one thing in
doctor Holden's video that I didn't
agree with which was like one sentence
he was talking about how we don't pay
enough attention to the the Friendly AI
possibility the positive outcome which i
think is true but then he said which i
think is more likely I don't know how
likely it is I think it depends on how
seriously we take this problem of how do
we actually make sure that any
artificial general intelligence we
create is friendly friendly you know I
don't think that it's a problem that's
solved and I don't think that it's a
problem that will solve itself I
actually think it's a problem that's
very difficult to solve and we are very
far from a solution or quite far from a
solution it's very difficult to say with
any confidence how far we are
but it's comparable to how far we are
from general AI itself we had a brief
conversation with Professor Brailsford
on exactly this and he said maybe this
is like cold fusion 50 years ago they
said hey in 50 years we'd be able to do
this and it's always in 50 years right
yeah and the thing is with historical
examples
you can go back and find historical
examples endless historical examples of
people claiming that something fantastic
is right around the corner when in fact
it isn't but the thing is you can also
find a lot of examples of people saying
that something fantastic is definitely
never going to happen and it's actually
right around the corner because before
we talked about efficient
self-sustaining fission reactions Cinda
in the AI video that is an example of a
situation where you have Ernest
Rutherford Nobel Prize winner extremely
eminent scientist so he split the atom
right well he was part of a team that's
forgotten and he was on the record
saying some people think that you could
use this as a source of actual energy
that you could reliably get energy out
of this that's they called it moonshine
said it was completely absurd right and
then you have Leo Szilard
who eventually did it he had the idea
now we don't know exactly but as far as
we can tell the idea for using neutrons
to make a self-sustaining nuclear
reaction occurred to him on the same day
that Rutherford was dismissing it as
nonsense this kind of thing can happen I
don't I'm not saying that it will that's
my point right you can find situations
where people are overconfident in
predicting something will happen you can
also find situations where people are
overconfident in predicting it won't
happen and it's just a function of the
fact that predicting is really difficult
my central point actually doesn't rely
on anything to do with time scales
really right I think we're a long way
away from all of these things but at the
same time I'd be very surprised if it
were more than 100 years or something
you know just because and again this is
what this is as dr. Holden said it's
it's kind of inescapable if we continue
advancing as we are we're going to get
there sooner or later we know it's not
impossible unless we wipe ourselves out
some other way or destroy our
technological capacity some other way or
we discover that the brain is literally
magic and not like Roger Penrose quantum
magic like actual magic then we'll get
there sooner or later right my point is
that the problem of AI safety is not
solved is not going to solve itself and
is not easy to solve and most
importantly we have to solve it
for we solve the problem of general AI
that's that's all I'm trying to say
really is that sooner or later we will
probably get general AI and when we do
we have to know how to make safe general
AI and currently we're we're a long way
from that over a long enough time scale
I think that human level artificial
intelligence is completely inevitable
then asked was that a human you were
talking to or was it a machine if you
can't decide that it's not human then
it's passed the test